of the youth was the first of
the slaves was Zaid
Ibn Harita.
Ibn mentions as well the of the
Jews and Christians to enter
into Islam. He says
and the
[Silence]
if we'll recall when he came
back to Khadijah and he
explained to her what had
happened, what had occurred.
She took him to Waraka Ibn and
the reason she took him to is
that
was literate. He was literate
and I was very unusual at the
time. Likewise, was very
knowledgeable about the
scriptures of Musa Alaihi
Salam. It's even mentioned that
he spoke or he was fluent in
Hebrew and was able to
translate parts of the Torah
into Arabic and as well
translate things from Arabic
into Hebrew. And another
narration, he was also other
narrations are also articulate
that he was likewise fluent in
Aramaic. Suryania. And so
had become Christian. And his
time because that's what he
found to be the closest thing
to the guidance of Allah of the
time. And when the prophet had
that first encounter with
Jibreel was the first to point
out to him that this is
Jibreel. This is the man, this
is the angel, the archangel
Jibreel who comes with
revelation to prophets. And
this is similar to the
revelation of Musa Alaihi
Salam. And so immediately
accepted Islam. There's not any
clear narration in the history
books to say that
necessarily said I accept Islam
or in that way. However, there
are narrations. In which the
prophet tells us that is in
paradise. There is in the
narration of what passed away
very very soon after that first
revelation to the prophet the
prophet commented on warakah as
was collected by he said that
he saw in a vision and he saw
in a good state of being which
is basically an articulating
that he was impaire dice. There
are other more explicit
narrations though they have
some weakness in their chains
that is in paradise and for
this reason when you look into
books of some of the scholars
that recorded all of the names
of the known companions Al
Islaba, Sahaba for Ibn Hajjr,
Rahima Allah, or also Uzdul
Gaba.
and others, you find that is
usually mentioned as one of the
companions of the prophet we
take a moment here to explain
what exactly a companion is A
companion a what makes a person
a a companion the scholars have
a very specific set of
criteria. That they have picked
up on that
a person must meet in order to
be considered a companion of
the prophet in the legislative
sense. A companion and this
tariff is very well known. Ibn
Hajjal Rahima Allah used this
definition of a companion and
he's most commonly known for
this definition and this exact
wording though he did earlier
take it from others El
Mizi and
and so forth and that is a
companion is
Thank you.
They say
number of times but when a
person is considered a
companion, they have to have
been in the presence of the
prophet physically and in a
state of Islam, in a state of
leaf. And then they die upon
Islam. This is the criteria. So
three things. They have to omit
the prophet and they have to
have met him while they were
Muslim. At least once. Even if
just for a moment. And then
they die as a Muslim. These are
the companions of the prophet
in the most broad sense. This
is an important set of criteria
because there are people who
believed in the prophet but
never met him. Those are not
considered to be companions.
They're almost companions.
They're considered to be and
the science of Hadith and their
narrations are usually just as
acceptable as the narrations of
the companions but they don't
have the level of
companionship, right? There are
those who met the prophet but
did not believe in him when
they met him. But they later
became Muslim after his death
or and they never met him
again. Such as Surah bin Malik
for instance. Was a bounty
hunter who sought to
get
the reward of a contract of
a bounty on the prophet when he
went out to when he was
migrating from Mecca to Medina,
he was intercepted by Suraqah,
Suraqah bin Malik. As is in
Sahih Al Bukhari, he attempted
to capture the prophet meaning
he attempted to kill him. He
was unsuccessful. And the
prophet said to him, do you
believe? And he said, no.
However, I promise you, I will
never against you or help a
people who fight against you.
So, he let him go. So, Raqab
and Malik never met the prophet
again as a Muslim. He became
Muslim in the time of Umar. So,
he is not considered to be a
companion. He's considered to
be a which is the highest rank
of the and so, is considered to
be by this definition, a
companion. He met the prophet
believing in him and died upon
that faith. And so is
considered to be a companion of
the prophet Ibn says
people then began to enter into
Islam one at a time. And there
was a steady consistent flow of
people entering into Islam
during this stage of the Dawah.
The
is not really bothered by this.
the disbelievers of Quraish,
they didn't really have a big
problem with this. Yeah, they
would kind of poke fun of him
and they to him but they didn't
have any serious pushback
against his Dawah until he
started to speak ill of the
religion of their forefathers
until he started to dismiss
their their gods and their
deities. This is when Quraish
became became hostile towards
the prophet and that is that
when we say he he insulted
their deities or their
religion. We're not speaking
about you know, vulgar towards
them. We're speaking about he
would say,
these different gods that are
worshiped by Quraish and
revered. These are not gods.
These are idols. It is not
permissible to worship these
aside from Allah. We do not
fear these things. These are
not gods. That is considered to
be an insult. They took this as
an insult and when the prophet
began to speak out against
their religion and some of
their evil and deviant ways and
innovations that they
introduced to the religion of
Ibrahim Alaihi Salam. This is
when Qura turned very hostile
towards him and his companions.
[Silence]
and high esteem amongst
Quraish. He was considered of
the nobility of Quraish and so
he protected the prophet the
best that he could. And even
the to an issue here and he
says and it is of Allah's
wisdom that Abu Talib did not
accept Islam. Abu Talib never
accepted Islam. He died upon
disbelief. And it's of Allah's
wisdom that he did not accept
Islam because it really changed
the dynamic of how he was able
to protect the prophet he
himself would have most likely
fallen victim to the same
hostility and persecution had
he accepted Islam but being
that he remained upon the
religion of Quraish but he said
look not from a religious
perspective but from a tribal
perspective it is unacceptable
for you to lay hands on my
nephew this made the dynamic of
his of his protection to be
very very different and very
effective He says,
Iru the
and as for the rest of his
companions, whoever had us was
a member of a strong tribe and
was able to seek their
protection and that refuge in
his or her tribe did so. Some
of the companions, they had
strong tribes. They were able
to do that. However, others of
the companions did not have
strong tribes. They were not
considered of the nobility or
notables. or they were
slaves or they were people that
didn't have any family in
Mecca. They're from some other
land and they moved to Mecca
because it was more
metropolitan.
and so, Mecca was considered to
be more cosmic politics. It was
more integrated. People moved
there that weren't from there
in order to trade because of
the huge influx of travelers
due to Hajj. So, people that
accepted Islam and they didn't
have a tribe to protect them.
They were turned on by Quresh
and they began to endure
extreme persecution by Quresh.
Of these people was Amar?
And his mother specifically and
also the rest of his close
family members. they were
persecuted and physically
tormented almost on a daily
basis. He says,
and the prophet was unable to
stop this. He he was beyond his
power to to make this situation
any different and the only
thing that could be done was to
be patient. And so when he
would see them being
persecuted. See them being
tormented. He would
consistently remind them and
say be patient. for indeed
your promise is paradise.
Paradise is for you. You just
have to be a little bit
patient. Of these individual
that were tormented physically
as well was Bilal. Bilal.
he was of the most severely
tormented from amongst the
companions.
he was not Arab and he was a
slave and he was tormented day
in, day out and it was almost
a sport for them. if
you read the narrations, if you
read the books that comment on
Bilal
and what he endured with his
torment you see that it was
kind of a sport for them,
right? They would torment him
to try to get him to say
certain things and he would
refuse to do so in order to
frustrate them because that's
the only thing that he could
do. And
they would try to break him.
And so they kind of made it
their prerogative, their
mission to try to break this
man and break his faith and
break his his his mind. And
they were ultimately unable to
do this.
Says
[Silence]
and who would see this and
comment to him and say of by
Allah, yes, oh Bilal, Ahad. I
concur.
The
[Silence]
Islam. Some of them left Islam.
Some of them were killed.
things started to happen and as
this torment continued, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala allowed
those who were able to flee
Mecca and able to migrate
elsewhere. He allowed them to
do so. So, a person might say,
well, I don't understand.
What's what's the big deal
about leaving? If you think
about it, you're there in
Mecca. You're being tormented.
Why not just move outside of
the city, move somewhere else
and just be over there, right?
It's not that because the
way that Mecca was, the way
that the tribes were set up,
right? It was literally like
countries. So, if Quresh has a
problem with someone, if and
they have
certain treaties with other
tribes no matter where you go
in the entirety of the Arab
Peninsula, you're not going to
find anyone to sell you food.
You're not going to find anyone
to sell you land. You're not
going to find anyone to allow
you to live in a certain place.
It's kind of how countries
are. You have a passport and a
passport is basically you
saying that look, I have, I
come from this country. I'm a
citizen there and this passport
is to essentially say to
whatever country you go to, I
the best of what your treaty
has to offer with my people.
That's what a passport is,
right? Well, if you could
imagine a passport that you
know, a person that is a
fugitive and they try to leave
with their passport wherever
they land, whatever country
they go to, most likely,
they're not going to let them
stay there and they're going to
consider them a fugitive.
They'll either take them back
or they won't allow them into
the into the country. the same
kind of thing. It's not just
that a person could, you know,
get up, gather his stuff, and
leave. It wasn't that easy.
There is a lot of tribalism.
There's a lot of treaties.
There's a lot of agreements
between the tribes and if
you're on bad terms with
tribesmen here and they have an
agreement with tribesmen over
here, you're going to be in in
a bad situation in both and
this did eventually happen to
where They were cut off from,
you know, fiscally. They were,
it was basically a financial
embargo that took place as
we'll get to inshallah. And so,
was allowed for people to who
were able to escape, to
completely leave outside of the
reach of that tribalism, right?
Cuz if you imagine with me,
there's a lot of tribalism but
it's not necessarily a country.
it's not an empire. The empires
where the Persian Empire, the
Roman Empire, the the Ethiopian
Empire, right? These were
really the empires that were
around and so, that tribalism
that was taking place in the
Arab Peninsula, they weren't
independently countries or
empires. They were always just
a part of the Roman or the
Persian Empire and so, when
they were able to leave and
escape the reach of that
tribalism, the closest place
that they could flee to was
Ethiopia at that time, Al
Habasha. And so, this is where
they fled but between the Arab
Peninsula and Ethiopia, there's
water. So, what they did was
they fled at night, very few,
and it Allah Allah had it time
just so that when they reached
that water, there were a couple
of merchants there that were
docked or getting ready to sail
across. and so, they took them
with them in their ships and by
that grace of Allah, they were
able to escape. Though they
were being pursued. The first
of those to make that hijra was
the third Khalifa and the
prophet son-in-law. He had the
prophet's daughter with him or
and there were twelve men and
four women. But we have just
around 20 people that made that
first migration, that first
hijra, right? And they made
that hijra, they made that
hijra to Ethiopia, to El
Habasheh. He says,
that this took place in the
fifth year after the prophet
prophethood in the month of
Rajab. So in the month of Rajab
Rajab is the seventh
month of the Islamic lunar
calendar. This month the fifth
year after he was appointed as
a messenger as a prophet. in
the month of Rajab, this is
when this first migration took
place. He says
[Silence]
in Mecca with the prophet and
they were trying to stay
abreast with any new
developments there. One of
those developments is that a
rumor started to spread that of
Quraish accepted Islam. and
this was not true, obviously,
but this was the rumor and this
was what was making the rounds
and so, those companions that
made that first migration were
of course, very thrilled and
they wanted to go back and be
reunited with their tribesmen,
with the prophet and so they
returned to Mecca. But what
happened is, as they came close
to Mecca, just little ways on
the outskirts of Mecca. They
found out that actually, not
only is that untrue but Mecca
has upped the ante. The Quraish
has up the ante against the
prophet and his companions and
they have become more murderous
and vicious than they ever were
previously. So, this now is a
conundrum. It's a problem. Do
we go back into Mecca and
become a part of that or do we
go back to where we came from?
What should we do? And Some of
the historians, some of the
Islamic historians mentioned
that the reason why that rumor
spread. was that the chapter in
Nejim was revealed to the
prophet in this chapter in
Nejim at the very end at the
last verse Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala there is what's called
referred to as a sejda and in
that sejdah the prophet went to
a gathering of the nobility of
Quraish. And he recited this
chapter to them. And they were
so captivated by it. They were
so enthralled by Surat and
Nejim. That they forgot to they
forgot to abuse the prophet
they just wanted to listen to
it. They didn't interrupt him
and they didn't abuse him. And
at the very end of this chapter
the prophet made sujood. Ibn
Masraud and also Ibn Abbas.
They mention in Bukhari and
Muslim that when he made that
sujood noone present refrain
from making sujood with him.
So, everyone, Muslim and Muslim
and non Muslim antagonist or
protagonist All made sujood
with the prophet due to the due
to the immensity and the
gravity of and so when they saw
all of these people making
sujood, Abu Jahal is making
sujood and ifflan and ifflan it
appeared to those around that
they had accepted Islam.
And so, a rumor started to
spread and make the rounds that
all of Quraish had accepted
Islam. They're all now Muslim,
all of Mecca is Muslim, and we
saw them all praying together.
Obviously, this is not the
case. And so, they headed back
to Mecca based on this faulty
intel and when they reach the
outskirts of Mecca, the truth,
the hard truth, saying and they
realized the hard truth. So,
whoever wanted to enter Mecca,
they either entered secretly.
basically smuggled themselves
into Mecca or they had to wait
on the outskirts of Mecca and
seek seek sanctuary from
different tribesmen that they
may know. And so the way that
this works is that let's say my
father was a friend of your
fathers. And you have such and
such tribe. So I say you know
look our fathers were friends.
Please grant me protection and
so I would come in under your
protection, the protection of
you and your tribes, right? You
and your tribe and this nobody
is going to really interfere
with that person because of the
politics that would be involved
with that. And so, there were
those who were able to enter
back into Mecca in this way and
then there were others who were
unable to enter back into Mecca
in this way and were forced to
instead
basically smuggle themselves
back into Mecca. He mentions
that one of these individuals
was Ibn Masud. Even Masud is
from Mecca originally and he
made the first hijara. And then
he and he entered into Mecca
during this time and he
stayed there with the prophet
until he made the second hijra
which was the major hijra to
Madinah with the prophet this
is what many historians
mention of them is even Isak he
is is the author of and it's
summarized by Ibn Hisham. So,
it's one of the most important
sources of the prophet
biography.
as his book Asira. This book is
lost. We don't have this book
anymore. This was lost many
hundreds of years ago. the
only remnants of the of Ibn has
is hack that we have is what's
known as and I'm sure we all
know the of Hisham. It's
considered the most expansive,
most well-known book on Syrah.
This book Sierra Tibin Hisham,
he summarized it from the book
of Ibn Isak. So, the original
work of Ibn Is Haq is Mafkud.
We don't have this book
anymore. The only thing that we
have is its summary which is by
Ibn Heshem. So, the only
narrations that we have from
Ibn is half is what was
delivered to us from Ibn, His
this book had it remained as a
very expansive book and that's
the book that has all of the
chains of narration in it and
so forth. Unfortunately, it's
been lost and now all we have
is Sierra and this happens in
the history of Islamic
scholarship. There are some
books that have become lost. We
read about them.
You know,
we read about these
books in the works of later
scholars but when we go to look
for the book, we it doesn't
exist anymore. We don't have it
anymore and so the only thing
that we have of that book is
whatever the scholars who used
it and had it at the time,
narrate to us in their books.
There's a lot of books like
this. a good example of this
is the Muslimt
the
has a very long story A very in
intricate and inspiring story
in which he traveled all the
way from North Africa to
Baghdad on foot. And he was a
contemporary of Imam Ahmed of
Rahima Allah. And on his
journey from North Africa to
Baghdad, he stopped at every
major village, every major
city, and collected near from
all of the scholars in his
path. So, he had the most
expansive collection on
narrations of the prophet ever
in the history of Islam. Also,
he had the biggest in the
history of Islam and he met
Imam Ahmed Ibn Hamble and so on
and so forth. the point is
is that this book, the Muslim
of is lost. We don't have this
book anymore.
we have scholars such as
a scholar of the seventh
century, right? So,
the mentions in his book CR
that he saw volumes of this in
his life. Ibn Hajab is the 9th
century scholar and he
mentioned in that he had seen a
few volumes of this book yet.
Somewhere between that time
until now, that book has been
lost. how did how did these
books become lost? You ask?
Because these books become lost
due to war. War. the crusades
had a huge impact on the
Islamic library Unlike the
Muslims and their scholars,
when Muslims would usually
enter into a land, most
important thing was the books.
They would take them, they
would translate them, they
would read them, they would
study them, they would preserve
them. The crusades did the
opposite. And also the invasion
of the the Tatter invasion
which was the Mongols. They as
well came and they had no use
for knowledge. They were not a
people of knowledge. They were
not literate. Most of them
were. very lay and and
illiterate. And so the first
thing they would do when they
would come into these big
Muslim cities, big Muslim areas
Davdad, Hashem, and
so forth, as they would take
all the books and burn them, or
they would take all the books
and throw them into the river,
right? They came into Egypt and
threw them in the Nile. They
came into Baghdad and they
burned them. And so some books,
that was the only copy. Some
books, there was only four or
five copies and that's all of
them, right? And if there's
only, you know, if you can
imagine a book that they have
to literally, there were no
printing presses. If you want a
copy of the book, you have to
write the whole thing. And so,
if you imagine has a book that
is 40 or 50 volumes, how many
copies are there going to be?
Three, four. Well, all of these
will be easily wiped out in
these kinds of crusades and
these invasions. So,
unfortunately, there are some
books that have been lost but
the bulk of Islamic knowledge
has been preserved by Allah's
favor and grace that's enough
for tonight to allow Mohammed.